first I check to see if they're
breathing because if they're not
breathing it's one of the key signs that
they're going to be a good story teller
teller of stories are a good listener in
fact they probably won't be good for
much anything so they are they breathing
then I try to acknowledge that if
they're breathing that they occasionally
laugh and smile when they hear something
that means they have some emotional
basis because telling preface little
stories is emotional transportation so
they have no emotion they don't cry they
don't laugh very itchy then a tired
they're not excited they're not able to
do anything they don't smile then we got
a problem i can't help those people they
can up themselves they need prozac they
need something else but if they want to
interface with the world and have the
world any pot one or many join their
club join their church participate in
your charity get a raise get a new job
help get somebody to work for their
company sell their product whatever they
want other people to do one of the
greatest tools of choice is using the
power of telling a purposeful story to
engage that person to transmit and
communicate the information analytics
data facts and figures into them which
they'll help metabolize which they then
can act on for this success hopefully
your success as well that's the way it
works when you tell a story any kind of
story and you aim for somebody's wallet
or you ain't look at them as customers
or clients or patrons they protect their
groin and they'll backside their wallet
that's what they do naturally your
maiming for transactions when you aim
for relation and you aim for their heart
that's what hits have one when it does
that it migrates to you had in your
wallet in other words you aim for the
perfect target is to emotionalize you're
offering so the person actually
metabolizes the information the data and
the facts in the form of a story and
there's two things axon it moves their
feet or their wallet creates a
relationship more than a transaction and
most importantly they become advocates
or Possible's for the position and pass
along the story as theirs that's the key
as theirs it's their joke it's their
stories their narrative and when they do
that it becomes viral
you
the reason I wrote this book tell to win
was because I thought here's a tool that
everybody has and so many people don't
use it's like walk you around think i'm
going to play golf and all i got is a
putter well you got 500 yards to get to
the hole to stop budding what are you
going to use all right all these tools
that you have in your tool kit for
telling purposeful stories you've been
wired you've been designed for God gave
you them they're in you that's how I
species survive that's all we prospered
so one of those tools they're magic any
one of them in telling a purposeful
story for your success to win can be a
game changer for you for all of us
understanding motivation not motivating
you motivating you your authenticity
make sure your intention is a line
before you walk into the room to tell
any story make sure your intention is
aligned because that's your authenticity
and it shines through before you speak
the first word your audience don't think
of them as customers a client think of
it as an audience they expect
experiences and that's what you're going
to deliver and that's what narrative
does deliver experiences but know what's
not what's interesting don't try to be
interesting be interested think about
what's in it for them make sure you
spend a little time to cut through the
cacophony of their noise disrupt it so
you have a good landing platform put
your tell then remember you have a goal
don't walk in without a goal know what
your goal is you're wasting your time in
this and don't hide it all they'll see
is you're hiding something pride it make
sure that goal is generous show you have
skin in the game show you have a real
understanding of what laughing and
crying together mains and then be
interactive remember you're not telling
a story in an empty vacuum or a vacuum
or emptiness you're telling it with
another human being or a group of human
beings lea be interactive engage them
don't make them passengers make them
participants that's what the internet
does you should do it in your life make
the participants engage them so the
metabolically they own your story and
then find a story anywhere content find
it anyway your life experience somebody
else's life experience history movies
and just embed the information it and
realize you're an emotional
transportation business move them make
them laugh pride cheer feel and they'll
remember that in from
that story forever and we'll buy your
product will join your club will join
your church will participate in your
company will be a customer and a client
on a relationship basis not just a
transactional one